hello welcome to science last week from
science mission we are going to discuss
three papers published in the week of
april twentieth let's start first we
will discuss an interesting paper from
valina dawson slab published in cell
reports this paper talks about a novel
mechanism by which watch controls not
signaling first let's look at the
literature and find out what is known
and what this publication is going to
unravel watch promotes embryonic
neurogenesis through inhibition of not
signaling notch processing and signaling
requires a s1 fear in like cleavage this
clever generates notch extracellular
domain in ec d and transmembrane
intracellular domain TM i see this TM IC
upon ligand binding to the any CD will
undergo s2 and s3 cleavage to generate
the intracellular domain nicd nicd
translocates to the nucleus and controls
gene expression watch prevents not
signaling by interfering with s1 furin
like cleavage step but the mechanism is
not known author show that watch has
gamma-glutamyl Psychlo transferase ggt
activity there is a similarity between
the structure of Boch and GG CT as shown
in the overlapped structures in this
figure if watch has GG CT activity it
should cleave gamma-glutamyl alanine to
alanine and phi oxy prolene as shown in
this schematic author conducted
experiments in vitro and showed that
indeed watch activity leads to alanine
as a by-product GG CT is used as a
control which also showed alanine after
the reaction authors also did catcher
to show the activity of watch and the
mutant watch the mutant protein did not
have any activity so authors
conclusively proved that watch has GG CT
activity in vitro his boch activity
required for neurogenesis and not
signaling yes as per the data shown here
our expression of gfp boch by injection
into mouse embryos showed more cells in
cortical plate and intermediate zones
then ventricular and subventricular
regions while control and inactive bot
showed less cells in cortical plate
intermediate zones and more cells in
ventricular subventricular regions
quantitation of the essay is shown here
authors also did knock out experiments
using small hairpin RNA and showed that
GG CT activity of botch is required for
embryogenesis data is not shown here to
determine whether GDC t like activity of
botch is required for regulation of s1
cleavage of notch flag notch one was
treated with furin in the presence or
absence of barge or botch in active
protein wild-type watch completely
prevents the fear in cleavage of notch
whereas watch inactive protein was
divided of the activity or expression of
watch in human embryonic cells lead to
an approximate to fold increase in
unprocessed full length notch with a
significant decrease in any CD but
inactive protein has no effect these
results indicate that watch blocks notch
on signaling through inhibition of the
fear in like cleavage of notch we r GG
CT like activity
author elicit ated the mechanism of
action of botch they incubated the
substrate gamma-glutamyl glycine in the
presence of GG CT barge or watch in
active protein both GG City and watch
release glycine by cleavage of
gamma-glutamyl glycine whereas watch in
active protein did not to determine if
ye 1669 that is glutamine toxic number
16 69 is required for the fury in like
cleavage of notch1 a conservative amino
acid substitution from glutamate to
glutamine was made at 1669 in notch flag
notch gfp or flag mute and gfp was
treated with fury in the presence or
absence of botch while type notch one is
cleaved by furin whereas mutant was not
to further investigate the impact of the
e 166 mutation on the processing of
notch war expression experiments were
done they also showed the similar
results release of any city in control
but not in mutated protein these results
indicate that watch blocks not signaling
by D glycine a ting notch at the amino
acid 1669 let's discuss the next paper
from keefe EU slab published in cell
reports DNA ligases are involved in many
aspects of DNA metabolism replication
repair and recombination all the
eukaryotes have two or three functional
DNA ligases 13 and for all are
atp-dependent DNA ligases 1 and 4 are
conserved in all eukaryotes whereas like
Age 3
is found only in vertebrates like s1 is
required to join Okazaki fragments
during replication while I guess 3 is
thought to be the primary ligase for DNA
excision repair like is for functions
exclusively in the non-homologous end
joining pathway that repairs DNA
double-stranded breaks delusion of any
of the three ligases in is incompatible
with mouse embryonic development in
contrast human [ __ ] mouth cell lines
lacking like s4 are viable mitochondrial
function of like s3 is essential for
cell viability but its nuclear function
is not like s3 deficient cells are not
hypersensitive to various DNA damaging
agents so the role of like is 3 is not
is questionable in DNA repair it is
possible that either like s3 is not the
primary language that functions in DNA
excision repair or that its function in
DNA repair can be efficiently
substituted by another like is that is
like a swan like is one is conserved
throughout evolution and generally
considered indispensable for cell
viability due to its well-characterized
role in DNA replication in order to
understand the role of like is one null
cell line was generated authors dudes
other northern western blot analysis to
confirm the knockout of the gene your
western is shown here with ligase one
knockout let's look at the effect of
cell proliferation on luggage one null
cells like s1 null cells display a
normal pleura ferretti capability with
or without cytokine stimulation like
ice-1 null
cells also do not show increased
sensitivity to a variety of DNA damaging
agents including zo seen cisplatin
hydroxyurea camptothecin but are
slightly more sensitive to methyl
methanesulfonate perhaps suggesting a
redundant role for ligase one in base
excision repair this is us demonstrate
that like a swan is not essential for
mammalian cell viability csr in legis 1l
cells was also measured since luggage
one and like history have been
implicated in joining csr associated
double-stranded breaks authors found csr
is not reduced in the absence of like a
swan next we will look into an
interesting paper published in pns by
Bennett on haughton slab on the
mechanism by which UV damaged DNA
binding protein to pass DNA and what
happens in the xeroderma pigmentosum
patients in nucleotide excision repair
how human DNA repair proteins survey the
genome for uv-induced photo products
remains poorly understood to understand
the mechanism authors performed single
molecule experiments and they found some
interesting results UV ddb performs a 3d
search mechanism and displace a
remarkable heterogeneity in the kinetics
of DNA damage recognition as shown in
the schematic here subset of
interconverting protein-dna confirmas
which form intermediates are shown in
the schematic here UV did it'd be
examined sites on DNA in discrete steps
before forming long-lived non motile UV
ddb dimers at the site of damage in
xeroderma pigmentosum patients
ddb is mutated and the mutants supported
dimerization but is found to slide on
the DNA and fails to stably engage the
lesions so this publication provides a
mechanism by which DNA in xeroderma
pigmentosum patients failed to get
repelled due to the mutant protein that
slides along the DNA without being able
to fix the mutation thank you for
watching science last week from science
mission